not necessarily pearl no you're being
harder than them and i'm not a sims
i'm not a sim let me just be clear sorry
it's just the time that you use like
left over
yeah that's what i'm saying still get
consumed though
past the expiry date oh at the same time
that's the buyer
no oh hush
what do you think about that let me know
i've been speaking enough what do you
think nah just
yeah i don't want to say anything about
this one all right over 35 i don't want
to think about it i'm too young for this
you're too young i worry about that when
i'm out and there's my approach in my
late 20s it's like
it can happen too don't worry about that
i'll say that this it could also be
sometimes it could be a good woman
that's been left because of a bad guy oh
yeah she's running your whole life in a
relationship or something yeah it could
be that too a good woman what that's
been
her or left by a by a bad guy
it might not even be her fault so she's
not really left over well she picked him
i literally think it's your own fault
i like how you think i like it and like
shop at any time
people can switch up at any time but as
a woman we have intuition and we just
talked about earlier how we always know
we just get that feeling
five years into your marriage what
imagine you've gone you spent three
years in your marriage now
and you got
the feeling but that's an exception
that's not that's not the rule like come
on you don't you don't know guys that
are stable committed good husbands and
after 30 years they just drop and leave
it happens it happens but it's not it's
not common
because women file 70 to 80 of divorces
if they're college educated they follow
90 of divorces
so women are the ones leaving it's not
man true we're living because of them
normally i think i take what you say on
board to be fair because i blame
myself in a way for my last long
relationship in four years
he cheated numerous times oh jesus and
essentially
it was
well i mean i'm going to blame myself
for him cheating because that was his
that was his choice
oh okay
yeah i picked him true you picked us
staying staying is another it's another
side of it right yeah i choose to stay
with him that's on me yeah yeah and i
did and now i'm 31 and i've been single
for four years yeah i take a part of
that
on on me because i shouldn't have stayed
for that long and wasted my time with
someone
who was consistently showing me that i
shouldn't have been with them so i do
take them on board
yeah
no i agree i just think like every in
relationships we we pick who like and we
attract what we are so if you keep
attracting shitty people it says
something about you
like no i'm serious good you're not
lying big facts like good good like
and
no one's perfect so
yeah but if it's like toxic relationship
after toxic relationship after toxic
relationship there's a part of you
that's toxic there definitely is there's
many bad women that choose
bad relationships over and over again
listen see when i talk when i was just
talking and i'm talking for the good
women like i can very much different
differentiate yeah the good women may i
say and the [ __ ] and the hoes i'm
very good at differentiating between
those particular sectors you get me so
if you're if you're moving a certain way
and then you've ended up on a pile
because you've been out partying every
night for the last 15 years that's your
fault i ain't going to say before you
you should have kept your ass indoors
try to be a better woman and the man
might have put a ring on it but instead
you was out in the club
doing all kind of madness twerking
busting it whatever you're doing and now
look at you you
just no but if you're like indoors every
day i don't think i didn't say every day
but come on there's not every day
there's a big difference between every
day and just
being out every weekend and stuff i feel
like there should be an equal balance
of course not but there must always be
balance but if you're out every weekend
what is there out every weekend for you
and you've got a man the men are always
out every weekend where they are every
weekend the menu no no no no no no no no
no no no no no it's the men you pick
that are out every year all right
there are a lot of good guys yeah
there you go that's what it is
because the mag my layout every weekend
my guy's like i can see by the way my
engineer there's nothing he's not out
every weekend sometimes you should just
call him he's here
yeah that's what that's my plan
that's a good hard man conscientious so
it's not every man out every weekend but
if you don't want to be out every
weekend don't complain because a lot of
times you're not going to meet the good
guy in the club people go to clubs and
bars for a reason at times you know so
and that man that is so quick to talk to
you like come on come on come on that's
the same thing he's done he's practiced
his art yeah you're not the first girl
not the first and you won't be the last
you understand so it is what it is so i
agree with you on that part but for the
good girls then there's hope but for you
like they're just expecting it to happen
in the same spot out every week
stumbling out drunk every week from the
club no we see you coming we see you
coming from a mile off we line you up
oh
i'm just telling you i'm just telling
you
the game the game is the game wow
the game is the game well that's what
i'm saying like a lot of girls confuse
sexual attention with relationships